[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from Google cloud we're
hosting webinars daily you are watching
from engineer to engineer a show where
you can hear from Google cloud customer
engineers about how to solve complex
problems on GCP based on real stories
from the customers my name is Stephanie
Wong I'm a developer advocate at Google
cloud and today we'll be talking about
networking 104 everything you need to
know about load balancers on GCP and
today joining me is Ryan frizzle
customer engineer and networking
specialist so just to mention you can
ask questions any time on the platform
and we have Googlers on standby to
answer them so take it away Ryan what
can you tell us about load balancer
thanks Stephanie so if you've seen into
previous videos we've done you know this
is part of a series so so far we've
covered VP CES we've covered a lot of
routing and peering some firewalls and
now we're on to number 104 which are
going to cover load balancers today just
as a note I've been giving some thought
to a session 105 and I think I'm gonna
cover DNS for that one so DNS is
something that interests you stay tuned
and we'll get to that next so this is
our product family when it comes to load
balancers the easiest way to think about
these is really are you dealing with
external load balancers I eat things
that touch the internet right outside of
Google cloud or are you dealing with
internal load balancers things that you
run inside the cloud environment the
other sort of dynamic to look at these
is are they global in nature or are they
regional in nature so all these products
kind of fit in these various boxes load
balancers are really important across
the entire GCP suite of services whether
you're running compute engine and
kubernetes engine and you're doing cloud
storage whatever it is you're doing load
balancers can be part of the solution
and part of the network architecture so
I'm gonna cover some of these I can't
cover everything in depth in the time we
have but I'll cover what I can and I'm
also going to show you how to actually
set up a little balance err as well so
let's get started with network load
balancers right so these are load
balancers that are really operating at
the network layer right so when I say
they're operating at layer 3 and layer
for right these are external load
balancers right so we talk about
external versus internal these are
facing the internet and these are
regional board balancers so what I mean
by that is they operate within Google
Cloud regions so in this example I'm
showing a number of users with that are
running a number of apps that are
running inside GCP in each of these
they're running in a different region so
you can see my app comm is running in
u.s. west test comm is running in Europe
and travel comm is running in Asia so
those are various regions for Google
Cloud in each case I have a load
balancer running in that region that is
receiving traffic from customers on the
internet and pushing them to in this
case my up comm or test comm on the back
side so let me go over sort of network
load balancers at a very high level so
you can understand the features that
come along with these so they all
regional they are highly available they
do run across multiple zones they are
designed to really load balanced TCP and
UDP traffic so as we'll talk about next
are layer seven load balancers these are
really operating at the network layer
right so when you're dealing with higher
layer protocols like SSL or HTTP all
that stuff just passes through here
right so if you're running things like
SSL your backends need be able terminate
that because the load balancers are
going to do it for you one of the common
questions we get asked is about
client-side IP in in terms of the
network load balancers the client IP is
preserved so when we talk about the
layer seven load balancers that isn't
the case when we get into the content we
call export for headers and different
ways that you can fit like that but in
terms of this the network load balance
where the client IP is actually passed
directly through the load balancer so
it's not terminating sessions it's not
changing anything because of that you
can actually use the VPC firewall
constructs that we talked about in a
previous video to actually enforce
security policy so if there's a regional
IP block that you don't want to allow or
something that you want a white list you
can use the firewall rules to actually
control that because the client IPS are
being preserved it passes through in
terms of how does it actually load
balance the traffic right it can use
either a two three or five tuple hashing
mechanism so if you're using a five
couple it's based on source IP DES type
e source port desperate and protocol
if you're using a 3-tuple its source IP
des type e and protocol and if you're
using just a to topple hash that's just
basically source IP and des type e it
actual maintains such an affinity based
on the IP address so session affinity is
something that comes up a lot when we
talk about load balancers so just know
in terms of the network load balancer
it's really basing that on the IP
address it does support HTTP health
checks in terms of the backends and
these are very high performance highly
scalable devices right they can handle
you know a million plus requests per
second so it's not something you have to
worry about it like how scale will are
these things yeah I think what you touch
on a bunch of things here you're able to
still enable that security whit by using
the firewall rules that you would apply
to the V PC subnet itself you know so
that doesn't change and then also this
is kind of the way that you're able to
scale your entire environment yep
exactly because it's a network layer
it's very transparent in terms of
traffic that's coming in and getting
pushed to the backends okay so a lot of
customers really like that function so
I'm gonna move in to serve our layer
seven load balancers so we call our HTTP
load balancers or Google cloud load
balancers first of all I talked about
DNS load balancing this is a topic that
comes up a lot with customers to say why
don't we use DNS load balancing as far
as you know how our preferred mechanism
a recommended way to solve this problem
so the challenge with DNS based load
balancing is kind of what I've
Illustrated here right so if you're
running multiple backends and they're
running in various regions what you have
to do is you have various DNS records
that are pointing in these various
regions there's a lot of things in there
that are outside of your control right
so for example you could have a failure
in say San Francisco right
you've got to update the DNS potentially
you could have people have stale DNS
entries so even if they're pounding away
on this and it's not available they
don't have those current DNS records
there's lots of things that are outside
of your control per se right and when
things fail that's what you've got to go
back and update this stuff so for
example if San Francisco fails you have
to make a change so that you could
redirect all the traffic to another
region so it's not saying that you can't
use DNS based load balancing it's just
not the way that Google has chosen to do
it we looked at this model and said when
you're running something globally how
can we do this that's different how can
you improve on this
model so this is Google sort of answer
to this so this is our layer seven load
balancer and this is a really powerful
construct right I always like to tell
customers this is like an IndyCar that
Google built that we just gave them the
keys for the reason I say that is
because this is the same load balancer
that we use for Gmail for YouTube for
our search engine we didn't build this
as a product to say hey cloud go sell
this we built this because we needed to
just to make Google function so really
it is this Indy car that we built in
Google infrastructure that we've said
hey go take it for spin around the track
yeah I was about to ask whether or not
this is built on the original
infrastructure that we're using
previously for our billion plus user
products exactly so the way this works a
noise is very different is start off you
have one VIP globally so in this case if
you're running my opcom in that regional
construct you had a different IP for
every region in this case you're using
201 1.1 in this case right so whether
you're in Asia whether in Europe whether
in America you're always hitting that
same IP right so what happens is when
you come in we're advertising a global
set of blocks so the various ISPs the
way that you get to Google or when I say
you the way it customers get to Google
to sort of access your my opcom is
they're gonna come in from the internet
somewhere so it's gonna hit one of our
load balancers and our load balancer
it's actually gonna look at all the
backends you've configured on the back
side and it's actually going to figure
out what is the closest one to it so
maybe you're running one on east west
coast and you have somebody come in from
Europe it's gonna push it to the west to
the east coast if you're running it in
all regions then if it comes in in
Europe it's going to land it in Europe
so net-net it gives your customer better
performance because that actually get
routed to the backends that are closest
to them right and this kind of reminds
me of like CDN as well yeah it's it's
very similar so our CDN actually kind of
lays parallel to this when you have CDN
content this is will be the first thing
you hit and then redirects it over to a
CDN to serve with the customers asking
for what this is sort of in concept how
it works you can see my about Jenn in
this example they're all hitting the
same IP and they're all getting pushed
to serving backends
right in their various regions now this
is one of the most popular things we
sell in terms of load balancing because
it just is so powerful lots of customers
even if they're running their own load
balancer stacks love with the fact that
we can have a nanny cast VIP globe
right that they can leverage here so
they made stack this load balance around
the edge and then put their load
balancers behind Fe it also has you know
when we talk about DDoS we talk about
also their stuff right this is what sits
at our edge this is what helps protect
against a lot of that stuff so again
it's a very powerful construct and just
to reiterate you mentioned the single
anycast IP why is that so beneficial and
such a differentiator for us so the big
thing there is you don't have to deal
with the DNS piece of it right so in the
case I showed you before you have an IP
address for one region IP address for
another each an IPO just another region
if a region fails you have to update DNS
records you have to make sure those DNS
records get propagated out right right
in this case you only have one IP right
so you never have to do any sort of
updating to the DNS records for this to
function you're always hitting in this
case 200 1.1.1 hmm right so no matter
where you are in the world you're always
hitting that same IP and you're letting
Google handle what region to push it to
that's closest to your customer to
really be the best customer experience
in terms of our load balancer and you
mentioned this because we have regional
load balancer as well but we have high
availability built into it it exactly
you can think of these as many many
processes that are running on Google's
edge right so as part of like how we
manage DDoS and how we sort of handle
that right you can think of these as a
process so when we need more of these
what do we do what we spin up more of
these processes so it's kind of in a way
I don't wanna say in fluently scale
because nothing's infinitely scalable
but it's a very highly scalable because
as we need more we instantaneously spin
up more of these load balancers handle
the incoming load and this is all based
on our Google front-end and that's kind
of the technology that it's sometimes
you can use the term GFE six at Google
front-end that's our internal
terminology for our global cloud load
balancer yes so I want to get into sort
of the data model how do you actually
build these things all right how do they
function so on the left hand side you
have the internet right this is where
all your customers are coming in the
first thing it's gonna be a global
forwarding rule right how you can afford
these right so you know WWE Stephanie
comm like four to one back end and WWF
ENCOM slash you know buy my cool stuff
my four different back-end right so when
we talk about those forwarding rules
this is what we're talking about how do
you forward based on the URL is it okay
this is gonna direct them to that target
proxy we actually build the URL Maps
right and then those map to back-end
services right so it could be you know a
web page it could be
in cart it could be you know anything
that you put out in the Internet right
so that is your back-end service and
then those back-end services really live
in what we call managed instance groups
right so I'll talk a bit more about
those when I set those up but
effectively you can consider those like
a scalable highly available way of
running that sort of back-end right so
whether that be that web server that
you're trying to get to or you know that
shopping application that you're running
right they're really running in that on
top of that managed instance group and
as we talked about earlier you've got
firewall rules firewall rules aren't
replacing here too to help control
traffic now in this case you're not
using the firewall rules okay we're at
the network load balancer because the
client IP as I mentioned before isn't
passed through the client actually
terminates out our load balancer so it
does SSL termination if those other
stuff terminates the session there opens
a new session on the backside right so
everything is private ip's inside the
only public facing IPS are really what's
facing out to the Internet and what the
customers are talking to your end
customers not you particularly and and
just go back that to that for just a
second you you just mentioned internal
IPS and that that reminds you of what
you're about to talk about it which is
internal load balancing at what stage
does it kind of become from external to
think about that it's a very good
question so let's take a shopping cart
application right so your shopping cart
application to be published on the
internet so you put that behind the load
balancer and the load balancers the
public IP for your application customers
come in from the internet they hit that
application right now that application
has to access inventory it has to access
a shopping cart rank sort of back-end
has to act all these are the things to
function okay it will use the internal
load balancer to then dovetail into all
those other applications running in the
back sites you're using the global IO be
up front to access that that web page or
that shopping cart and the shopping cart
is using the internal load balancers to
access all those other things on the
back against a function right okay so
let's run through some of the features
that are really tied to our later seven
load balancer so we talked about the
single global anycast VIP right and this
can be ipv4 or ipv6 right and it runs
globally worldwide capacity we talked
about this right these are processes
that run out at Google's edge they're
highly scalable and like I said we use
these for things like our search engine
so we know
they're tried they're tested they run
really well cross region failover and
failback so this is kind of what I was
talking about earlier you might have
instances running in all regions but if
say something fails in Europe guess what
the load balancer knows Europe is not in
commission at the moment I'm gonna fail
that to say the east coast of the US
because that's the next closest region
or if you're in the you know west coast
of the US and it fails it's gonna say oh
I know my next closest is the central
region so all those all that
intelligence lives with the load
balancer and it figures out how do I get
it to the closest back-end última give
your customer the best experience
awesome we talked about auto scaling in
terms like how we use use with like DDoS
and various other things right so it's
incredibly quick it's also a single
point to apply global policies right so
we talked about URLs various sort of
security policies you can overlay on it
we're not gonna talk about cloud armor
here but cloud armor sort of works and
function with this if you want a
whitelist or blacklist IP blocks all
that stuff works in conjunction over the
top of these layer seven load balancers
okay and again super robust millions of
queries per second right they wouldn't
function for our search engine if we
didn't have that sort of capability in
there right okay so as you said I'm
gonna pivot to the internal load
balancers right so these are things that
are not facing the internet they're not
facing externally these are facing you
know typically can think of like VM to
VM inside your cloud environment so one
of the key things understand here is
there really is no load balancer right
when you go and configure a load
balancer you're actually configuring the
control plane right our Sdn control
plane it's not like you're building a
box that's running on top of the VM
right because that would create a
bottleneck right so by basically
allowing you to program the Sdn directly
when packets come in and they need to be
a load balance the Sdn just sort of
looks on the nose oh I know that there's
four backends for this I'm gonna pick
one I'm I sent to the back-end right it
doesn't actually forward it to a load
balancer the load balancer doesn't make
a load balancing decision and then
forward it to one of the VMS right so
you know why we chose to do that is
again we don't want a single point of
failure I don't want something that can
fail when we start talking about the Sdn
in the control plane if it's failing we
have other very larger issues that would
rank
so the data model this looks a little
bit different right so in this case you
have a client VM so I can set your
shopping cart application you have IP
addresses right so backends what VMs are
they when IP is what ports of protocols
are using on them
the serving capacity and the instance
health will talk about manage instance
groups when I show you how to actually
configure these things but effectively
that managed instance group is gonna be
health checked right so what do I mean I
say health check like we're actually
probing it to say is the instance or
instances healthy if the instance in the
group is not healthy let's Auto heal it
right so we'll actually spin it back up
and you know if let's say you're running
two and one fails we'll spend up another
one and now you've got your two again it
also allows you to dynamically scale
these right so if you think about let's
say Black Friday is a really good
example right I'm running a whole bunch
of backends and I get a whole bunch of
customer traffic hitting you know my
shopping app well you need more backends
you can set the managed instance group
to scale the stuff horizontally right to
build more battens for you dynamically
to allow you to scale that traffic up
the great thing about is it dynamically
scales up when traffic goes away it
dynamically will scale that back down
right so you set all that stuff up
that's incredible because that again if
you can scale down to one let's say at
minimum then you are you know achieving
a lot more cost savings that way yeah
it's really good point I always
recommend running to so if one is always
one available so I kind of considered to
the minimum but yeah you're right you
can actually set up just one yeah yeah
and here it's like these are homogeneous
VMs like let's say an app server and it
gives you a failover capabilities and
the ability to auto scale based on
health checks or whatever configuration
that you set right based on VM
utilization or CPU utilization for
example exactly so now we're gonna talk
about some of the features for these
network load balancers these are the
internal load balancers right so just
like the external load vectors they work
on a VIP right so there's gonna be an IP
address assigned to them so when traffic
is coming from your front end like your
shopping cart app and it's going to the
backends it's gonna go to a VIP right so
you may have five VMs that are the
backends but they're all nested behind
that single VIP right so what really
happens is the Sdn will say oh I see I
know that VIP is configured as a load
balancer
I know these five VMs are on the back
side and it's gonna pick one of them
send it the VM is gonna receive it it's
gonna see oh this isn't
IP address per se but it's a it's a VIP
that I know that I'm the back end from a
load balancer so I can receive that
packet I can process that packet and I
can respond to that packet we talked a
little bit about health checks TCP HTTP
HTTPS health checks this is really sort
of what what it uses to check and make
sure those backends are healthy in this
case the client IP is preserved so we
talked about that because you're dealing
with VM to VM here mmm most cases right
so we're maintaining VM A's IP address
when you send to those backends right so
that's really what we're saying we say
the client IP is preserved it is really
the VM IP and we talked about there's
really no there's no metal proxy there's
no actual sort of chill point in this
right because you are configuring the
Sdn directly right so that's how we
deliver super highly scalable capacity
here to do this where there is no sort
of choked points or are things that can
be it's not a server it's not a VM it's
not a physical device yeah you know if
you've configured like f5 load balancers
or something in your data center it's a
physical device that you put in there
and there's nothing physical about it's
just a control plane configuration right
right so it's it's very elegant and it's
implicit different way of thinking
honestly with us yeah yeah there's a lot
of stuff that Google does that really we
embody this theory of you know why make
it more complex and we have to if we can
simplify and make it more elegant and
yeah and and simple let's go you know
what's dude yeah absolutely okay so
that's my high-level overview of this
now I'm actually gonna take you into
configuring a load balancer so since our
global load balancers the layer seven
one is the IndyCar Ferraris I was sort
of talking about our probably a you know
a very common used application I'm gonna
take you through how to configure one of
those so if you have ever been in our
console you'll recognize this as a sort
of the home page at a console so in
configuring a global load balancer you
have to actually do a few things before
I can figure the little bouncer we
talked about managed instance groups
right I didn't really touch on them
super in-depth but I'm gonna show you
how to actually configure a managed
instance group because that's what you
use to put behind the load bouncer or
what I used in my case okay so let's go
and look at that so when you click on
compute engine you're gonna see instance
groups and instance templates before you
can build a managed instance group you
have to have a template
for the VM that's gonna be in the group
because the group basically will spawn
copies of that particular VM that you
specify right so it's not like you can
have five different types of the ends
right throat if you say VM a looks like
this the man gin screw might be five VM
a s right the instant template is gonna
find what does VM a look like okay so
that's the first place we're gonna go
now
I've pre-built one because it takes some
time to update these things specifically
when you go and do the actual load
balancing computer seems like I said we
have thousands of these processors
running out there and you can imagine
how long it takes to push all these new
configs out to all the stuff right so I
intentionally can pre configure the
stuff so you wouldn't have to wait for
me for five minutes much little things
spin around yeah but I'm gonna show you
how to create an instance template so
there we go so this is an instance
template as I said you're basically
configuring a VM here right so you're
gonna give your VM a name you're gonna
give your VM a type right so whether
it's n1 standard and f1 micro if you
don't anything in compute engine these
are all things that are familiar to you
you can set things like boot disks
identity access management these are the
service accounts all the stuff can be
set I'm not gonna go too much into
detail on these you can set automatic
firewall rules that will be created to
allow HTTP and HTTPS and then you've got
this ability to go in here and sort of
define some of the networking parameter
so I'm gonna go specifically into
networking so in this case I've created
the network in this case it's load
balancer demo network so I would pick
that and then I would pick a subnet
that's in that network right so what I'm
telling it is all these VMs are going to
live in that V PC in that particular
subnet that I've created okay can you
actually have a managed instance group
with VMs in different regions
you could run things where they're in
different regions in this case I said
everything up in US central right so
this is a global load balancer so you
can build those backends as I was saying
you can build the instance groups so it
actually expands right you'd actually
build probably instance grouping like
the central region another instance
group in the West right okay individual
response occurs in different regions and
don't have the global load balancer
distribute between those yep so there's
a whole bunch of other configurations in
here I'm not gonna go through every one
of you using depth you can play with
these at your will but this is how you
create a template so again this is sort
of the
first step alright so I'm gonna go back
so this is this is the specific template
that I built in this case so you can see
I'm running an n1 standard it shows it's
in use by something I have some firewall
rules set up for it it's got an
ephemeral external IP address service
tears I'll talk about just a minute
whether it's premium or not so these are
all the configurations I just sort of
showed you but this is this this is the
instance template that I used so once
you have an instance template now we're
gonna create them managed instance group
itself so here's the manage instance
group that I created but to create your
own you'd go up here and create instance
group so you're going to you have the
option of managed or unmanaged I talked
about things like health checking I
talked about things like auto scaling I
talked about things like auto healing
that's all part of the managed instance
group - you're letting Google manage all
that stuff for you right so in this case
I created a managed instance group so
I'm gonna give it a name whether I
wanted to live in a single zone or
multiple zones so I would pick in my
case I configured something in US
central one you can configure various
zones and they're the ABCD redundancy
zones and then here you see it requires
instance template this is why I had to
build the instance template before I
could build a man Jensen okay so here's
where I would grab that template that I
just built click on it say this is the
template I want you to use as you build
and scale this managed instance group
auto-scaling because I've been a
management subscrib so I'm setting auto
scaling on its auto scaling based on CPU
utilization but there's different things
that you can do so in this case I just
picked CPU utilization I specify the
percentage so once it exceeds an
aggregate slice I'm running three VMs
once the aggregate CPU utilization
exceeds 60 percent it will spin up with
other ones Palance one right it add it
to the pool in this case I've told the
maximum number of instances I want to
run is ten so I might say here let's say
a minimum of three maximum of ten okay
good to know so you don't wake up and
there's a thousand running nope the
cooldown period is actually how much
time it takes to spin this up so
depending on your VM and what you have
configured on it right so if you're
running a bunch of startup scripts or
your boots dropping that or you're
loading a bunch of stuff on right yeah
the VM could take longer startup so this
is effectively how long
you want it to wait before it starts
pulling that thing to get information
out of it all right so right now default
is set for 60 seconds and then I've
talked about Auto healing this is like I
mentioned if the device were to fail so
if the VM fails so one of your three
let's say were to fail it won't just go
down to two it will recreate that one
right because we've got we define the
template so we can just go to the
template say I need to create another
one of these devices create another one
and boom due back to three okay right
but that's why I always kind of
recommend running a minimum of two yeah
right so if one fails one's always
running nothing saying you couldn't just
run one if it fails then four so you've
got a bunch of stuff on their boots
dropping it takes three minutes from
yeah and it's if you can put me down so
basically you just have another VM at
least running just so it could fail over
more quickly than having exactly been
yeah so you would have to wait the three
minutes well right you know brought up
another VM so that's why I was going to
say best practice is to run two of these
that's the whole kind of purpose of a
managed instance group is to allow for
failures but still have resources to
deal with stuff so in this case I can
set that different types of health
checks that I want and then we just
click create and that would create this
managed instance group so I'm gonna go
back to here so as I said I've already
created a management instance group so
we can click on and we'll look and see
what I set up so in this case I'm
running two different VMs right and you
can see the templates that I used that
was the template I've built initially
mm-hmm you can see you when I created
them I could these back in May you can
see I specified US central sea and US
central B so I'm spreading these across
the VM redundancy zones in our US
central and Davis okay and then you can
see there's internal IPs and external
IPS for these right now I do want to
show you if you go over to VM instances
you will see these show up right so
these are that same sort of the VMS okay
so what I did to show you some of the
load balancing in most cases you would
build say a temp like that but to say
it's a web server okay
you build three copies of it well if I'm
showing you load balancing and slow
balancing the same three copies the web
server I can't really show you that it's
actually working right so what I did is
I built these two VMs and I went I
loaded Apache on one and I've loaded in
nginx basic nginx proxy configure on the
other that way you can actually see so
of them what I'm gonna show you so if I
grab this 47 IP address all right let me
go over here you can see there's my
Apache that I said okay and if you go
back here and you grab the 50 there's my
Internet all right yeah so now I can
actually show you that it's actually
load balance and when I show you the
load balancing and figure this thing
you'll be able to tell I'll show you how
it's flipping back and forth but if it
was in normal cases you wouldn't do this
you would say build three copies of your
saying you know web applications are at
its load balancing across all three and
it's completely transparent to your
end-users right or your clients like
what's actually happening in the back
side but again it doesn't look like much
if I just show you the same three pages
I could be tricking you and you really
just have one thing running exactly I
didn't want to do that okay so as I said
if you go back to VN you'll actually see
the VMS running in here right so I just
want to point that out so we went we
built the templates we built the
instance groups now we're actually going
to build the load balancer itself right
so we're gonna go to this and again
here's the load balancer already set up
but I'm gonna go through and create a
load balancer for you right so as I said
we're creating a layer seven a GCL B
load balancer so that does this I'm
going to start that configuration from
the Internet to my VMs so these are all
the configuration profiles that you have
to set up to actually set up the load
balancer right so we're gonna use all
the other stuff we already created but
this is the actual when we talk about
the load balancer config this is what
we're really talking about okay so let's
go through it so first we need some of
the backends right so in this case you
could use buckets if you had buckets set
up but in my case I am running services
so I'm going to create the backend
service right or I already created that
back-end service right so I showed you
the manage instance group which is
really the backend service this was the
manage instance group I created right
the web backends so in this case I can
just click on it but let's go and create
a service right so you need to give it a
name you can pick whether you want use
instance groups or endpoints in this
case it shows the instance group that I
had already
it's an HTTP load balancer so port
numbers gonna be 80 okay
in this case I set those up the manage
interest groups as utilization if you
recall but I said that sixty percent so
it's pulling all the information that's
saying okay utilization where I want the
CPU realization to be so this is sort of
you know an easy way to just sort of set
this up using all the other stuff I've
already configured right yeah so this is
really just like I said configuring that
back-end
okay let me cancel out of that
okay so now we talked about host and
path rules right so this is where I was
telling you like WWE Stephanie calm you
know is one page and W Stephanie calm
/by my cool stuff is directing to
another instance gray right so this is
where you're setting all of this stuff
up right so in this case you can say the
default will be unnie any matched right
so anything that comes into Stephanie
comm regards to other back slash images
or backslash by my stuff right it's
gonna go to the back end so in this case
I'm gonna go back here and do this real
quick I'll grab that okay so I set that
set that up so now you can see it
populates it here okay so you could have
you know Stephanie calm a back-end
service for that you could have
Stephanie calm for it so I should buy my
stuff being a different app that you're
running
yeah bit different thanks to scrape
right so then you would just add a path
rule you could say you know we said W
know it's or we'll call it web duh
Stephanie calm /by my stuff and then I
could set a different back-end service
now in this case I've only create one
back-end service right but yeah you
could create other ones right so this is
where your mapping we talk with this URL
map right this is where you're actually
setting all those things up got it okay
so let me just go and delete this real
quick okay so now we're talking about
the front-end right so this is the
actual load balancer itself that
front-end load balancer so we're gonna
give it a name it's an HTTP or HTTPS
load balancer I'm gonna just make this
keep it really simple
make it an HTTP load balancer premium
versus standard
tear this has to do with Google's
backbone right so I saw you had
mentioned this earlier I told you to
talk about it so really what this is is
Google has a philosophy if we wanted
control your traffic as much as possible
in terms of the user experience right so
if you select premium network what that
means is if you have something in say
the East Coast but the users on the west
coast we're gonna use Google's backbone
to deliver that traffic all the way to
the west coast right because when it's
on our backbone we control that quality
right we can make sure that that packet
is not getting bogged down in the
internet or being congested by things so
that's what premium tier is now standard
tier was designed to help cost manage
this stuff right so what happens in
standard tier let's take our East Coast
origination device it would say dump it
off to an isp in the east coast that isp
you would pick up that packet and take
it all the way to the west coast but
again you're not using Google's bad
right you're just using the Internet at
large right okay so that's the
difference here so I'm gonna leave it as
premium okay say his ipv4 it's going
from address port 80 okay that's pretty
much it right so I would review and
finalize this so once I would click
create it's gonna take a few minutes to
create all this stuff and it's gonna
have a roll it out all those load
balancers out there right this is where
I didn't want you to sit and watch this
thing spin for the next you know 5 10
minutes so I'm gonna go back but I will
show you this is the load balancer that
I created right so we talked about how
to set up all the stuff right HTTP
here's the IP that was reserved for it
so we'll grab that in a second I set up
this premium tier and this shows you
sort of all the backgrounds behind it
right so it shows you it's an instance
group where it's running 2 out of 2
inches are healthy right so set up all
the health checking when I did this so
it's right it's constant pulling this
stuff to make sure it's healthy CPU
utilization at 60% max utilization at
80% it's pretty much the concern is the
IP that you're directing traffic to
correct this is the external IP address
that's facing external right right so
users would be hitting that exactly my
app comm right sort of used this side
okay address again single anycast IP
that's the only one that you would need
yeah so if when you're in this screen
you can quickly look and look at your
backends right so this is going to show
my back-end that I've built writes a
back-end service there's the name of it
I can click on and get some details
it's an HTTP back-end this shows your
load balancer again that actual
front-end load balancer right so I'm
gonna grab this IP at this point copy it
let me see if my load balancer checked
in here's what your config looks like if
everything is healthy see this green
check yep right one back-end service one
instance group everything's working
right so you get this nice green
checkmark right in that instance group
you can look here if you click on this
you can sort of see graphical
representations of traffic I've got
really nothing hitting on this but you
know it's one instance group back there
yeah and if you call when I set up the
instance group I set up for two so we
adding two right so and you recall ones
the nginx lose the Apache okay I'm gonna
close these out okay so what I did is I
copied let's see where is it I'm gonna
copy this IP so remember this is the IP
of the load balancer go back here I'm
gonna run that bad boy there's my Apache
okay i refresh it
there's my nginx there's my Apache I'm
just keep hitting on this and refresh
you can see it's just wow it's a pretty
much like 5050 yeah between them but
it's kind of going back yeah but you
know but you can see in this case right
like I'm trying to demonstrate it like
you wouldn't really set it up this way
you'd want your webpage to wrap every
time right yeah you're a shopping cart
but I thought it's like a representation
of how you know you would be balancing
the load between exactly a number
exactly this is a really good way to
drive visualize oh it's actually doing
this I'm just I just keep hitting it
yeah and just you know continue to
bounce around between these things right
right
and so and so the the front-end load
balancer that we you just created that's
handling that's being handled by our
global load balancer GCL be using all
the internal load balancer is what we
first created using the manage in this
case I'm gonna use the IO B at all I
just have this this is really just a web
page okay sitting behind a GCL B right
now if this was like a shopping cart app
or this was a you know say a store like
I'd see or something like that right you
know and I wanted to click on things to
go
things that would then use the aisle be
potentially to dovetail into other
things on the backside but purposes of
this I'm just showing you that front end
okay how that's changing and load
balancing the trash got it and right
then but if you were like I said Etsy or
something like that you know this would
always look like Etsy's homepage every
time got it so that's pretty much how to
configure a global load balancer thank
you so much I was super helpful I know
is a highly requested topic much more to
talk about in the next networking 105 so
that's that's it for the presentation
portion of the talk so please stay tuned
because we're gonna come back for
frequently asked questions we'll be back
in less than a minute thanks again
you
all right so we're back with some FAQ
the first being whether you know our
load balance actually require
pre-warming to scale because I know that
the concern that some yeah we get that
question a lot and some of that comes
from legacy products that are out there
in the industry yeah right where you've
got to define things right
I think the keynotes that is the key
answer is no you don't have to right but
part of this is because again we built
these load balancers as not a product
for cloud to sell but for things like
our search engine to function so as you
can imagine if there was you know a
disaster someplace in the world the next
10 seconds I can't predict that
right and we would get you know just
tons of searches of like what's going on
in country X that just happened or heard
something great on the news that I need
to research right so it would be
impossible for us to sort of do any sort
of pretty warming right so this is why
you know these things that were built as
a product right they they have some of
those limitations in it but when we
built our global load balancer this just
wouldn't have worked for us right yeah
just wouldn't have worked for our search
engine it wouldn't have worked for
YouTube when things go viral right yeah
so the ultimate answer is no you don't
have to do it but a lot of its because
just the Google engineering that when do
this and how this was not developed as a
product for route but rather something
we use to just make Google's
infrastructure work right yeah is that
sort of linchpin device for us yeah and
I think you mentioned you know in the
presentation that we're not we're
straying away from focusing or basing it
off a DNS approach we're using our
global front-end for the external for
the internal it's not proxy based it's
using our software-defined networking so
that's kind of like what enables us to
be able to not require the pre-warming
it's not based on physical service as we
talked about so the next one okay so we
mentioned premium versus standard
networking and you you talked about how
you know premium utilizes a Google
Network backbone and it gives us higher
bandwidth and throughput and standard is
for cost savings so for the front-end
specifically front-end load balancer can
you do premium tier for both like global
and regional yeah you can set up either
premium or standard here for either load
balancers right and like I said it's
it's really done to sort of cost manage
traffic more than anything right Google
has built this great big network and we
want you to be able to use it right so
we love for you know people to use
premium tier because it just gives a
better user experience and our view of
the world right but we also understand
that customers are trying to cost
optimize traffic sometimes right so
that's why we crew
sort of that standard tier where you can
say hey Google you have this great
backbone but it's just it costs more
money they want to spend on this traffic
so dump it off to the Internet as
quickly as you possibly can and you know
let it sort of go through the internet
and go through all of the cost structure
that is right flex in terms of it yeah
right depending on the use case yeah but
it isn't sort of you know you can set it
up in a lot of the different fashions
whenever you you'll see premium as a
standard and a lot of load balancer
configurations simply the external
facing ones because the internal ones
remember it's all just riding on
Google's it's meant to be inside of EPC
so it's all writing internal to Google
right it's not something that ever
touches the internet so it's really all
of the as I said early on the first
slide right you can think of internal
services versus external services the
premium standard only applies to
external load balancing service ok
understand great next one so the load
balancer is high availability or highly
available what can you do to increase
the availability of your backends so
this is where the managed instance
groups come in right this is the whole
points of the management's and scripts
right you're building highly available
in highly redundant managed instance
groups right so as I was talking about
with the GCL be you could build mansion
scripts into every region it'll find the
closest one right and that's what gives
you that sort of highly available highly
scalable right I like to talk about
Black Friday as a good use case for this
right if you're in the retail industry
if you do anything versus purchasing
that is the day you have to engineer
around right everybody engineers are on
Black Friday mm-hm
but doesn't make sense right why do you
want to run a thousand servers or why do
you want a thousand load balancers that
it get used you know call it one week a
year yeah right so that's where the
managed instance groups come in it gives
you that scalability and that that
protection from a highly available sting
and point where if something fails we
spin it back up is you're letting Google
manage that infrastructure yeah so that
whole concept of using a managed
instance group is really designed around
making highly available back-end
infrastructure awesome great ok I think
this is the last one how about
connection draining for back in
instances to reduce disruption to end
users like you know let's say you want
to move from one back-end to another
without any kind of poor experience for
the user so this is another common
question right so when we do auto
scaling and things scale up right so
let's use our Black Friday example right
midnight happens a sale goes on and you
get bombarded with all this traffic's
you scale up to you know
ten servers on the backside right
there's a there's a variable in in the
configuration that didn't show that
basically says what is the draining
period right so I think it defaults to
300 seconds okay
so what's gonna happen is as traffic
starts to ramp down yeah right so let's
say maybe four o'clock in the morning
you know you've got your initial barrage
you've scaled up to meet with it you to
meet that demand now things start to
fall off right when it sees the
utilization go down what it's gonna do
is it's gonna say okay all new
connections I'm gonna drain this this
back-end right so I'm not gonna put any
new connections on there and oh wait 300
seconds before I take it out of the pool
right so let's sessions finish let's
yeah it's like drain off of it and then
because it's not putting any new ones on
it it's putting new ones over here yeah
once it's down it'll pull that one down
and it'll keep doing that and scaling
down is your load that's great because
then they don't experience like just cut
off and then you know we're still kind
of spinning out this direct intelligent
in terms of like it knows oh I'm in a
cool-down period right where I need to
scale this stuff back yeah and it does
so in a very in television way right it
doesn't just say oh you know I'm gonna
go back to to dump all these other five
and I spun off and yeah and all these
cost it's like slowly redirecting
traffic and users to the other one okay
and like I said you can figure that sort
of stuff yeah or when you're setting
these things up awesome this is super
helpful and thank you so much again Ryan
thank you everyone for tuning in today
and again don't forget please visit the
cloud on-air website for more content
from Google cloud experts and we'll see
you again next time
[Music]
you